[Music]
let's go to
megan in milwaukee what's up megan how
we doing
i'm pretty good thanks how are you we
are rocking and rolling
rock and roll so pretty good so what
does that mean tell me what's going on
so my question for you today is how do i
set boundaries with my family
um after my dad's cancer diagnosis being
the only
medical professional in my immediate
family
oh no what a great question and what a
miserable place
so tell me about your dad man
so my dad was such a hard worker i mean
he was the type of guy that
would help anyone out no matter what day
what time he would always be there so he
was a guy who worked
like six seven days a week never
complained always
you know how can i help someone and so
this past
fall um started getting sick which he
is typically never sick so after a
couple of weeks of in and out of the
doctors
um we found out that he had stage four
renal cell carcinoma
so what's the prognosis is there a
timeline they've given y'all
so they haven't really given us a great
timeline by any means but
like five-year survival rates aren't
good for stage four
yeah yeah so i mean within a couple
weeks of that diagnosis we found out
that um he had a brain tumor so
it's it's kind of been one thing after
another he was hospitalized for a couple
months
and obviously navigating this in a
pandemic has been
a nightmare that's kind of the extra
layer exactly yeah
and so what what's what's your
profession you're a medical professional
you a doctor a nurse practitioner what
do
you
what do you do i'm a nurse practitioner
okay
yeah yeah dude so
here's the it's this is a a simple
fix and it will feel hard
um and if anybody well
it's as simple as this do you have
brothers and sisters who's who's
contacting you everybody mom everybody
so it's my brother really isn't in the
picture right now he's had his mental
health issues over the years
um so it's really my sister and my mom
okay and pretty much
you know the calls initially were what
does this mean
how do i navigate health care right kind
of the logistical questions
and now the questions i'm getting are
more i mean from my sister she's called
me
numerous times saying well when is he
going to die is he going to make it to
his birthday
like some of those questions which of
course i don't have answers to
right um and my mom kind of goes back
and forth between
you know i just hear fear and you know
being overwhelmed
constantly in her voice um and
so she at times is saying well he's
declining i think he's going to die soon
and then other times it's well no one's
giving us a straight answer
and you guys as healthcare professionals
and so sometimes they get looped into
the u
of healthcare yeah so you're trying
you're trying to
offer support while offering information
but yet you know
especially during the pandemic like i'm
not at
these office visits i've gone to i think
one of his visits
i'm around and like i work next door to
the facility where he
receives his care so like i'm physically
nearby
but the i think the questions that they
have for me most of the time i don't
have answers to or the answers i have
are not you know i think i think for
both of my parents we were thinking that
there's light at the end of this that
oh well cancer is not going to be around
his entire life
gotcha and i'm seeing the other aspect
where it's like
he may not be around in the next five
years that's right and so trying to have
some of those conversations
while also not wanting to overwhelm my
mom
and also not having the full the full
story because i'm not at
all the appointments uh yeah
so it's really common
for people who do this for a living what
you do
to be faced with it personally and have
it be unmooring
because you've may have
talked to a thousand struggling moms
or struggling wives who are looking down
the barrel of becoming a widow
right or you may have met with thousands
of people who
get a prognosis that is not good or
whatever that happens to be
and then all of a sudden it's dead and
all your
academic training and all of your
experience goes out the window because
that's dad
right and then
everybody handles it differently just
you describing your mom was a i mean
that's just
ping-ponging through elizabeth
kubler-ross's stages right
like i'm denying this this isn't real to
oh my gosh she's gonna die today
to you people i'm angry right it's just
that's just that
she's in a grieving state and she will
be for the next 18 24 months until this
thing
um probably takes his life and so
i think at the end of the day the best
thing to do is to sit down with your mom
and sister and be as honest with him as
you just were with me
and let him know hey i am a nurse
practitioner
one of the things i agree to do to
people who i love is i will interpret
and so i'll be an interpreter um if
somebody calls and says hey my kid just
got diagnosed with this or i just got
this meds what does this mean
i will say this is what that means to me
not gonna give you counseling care for
your kid i can't be that person for you
i'm gonna be your friend
right i can't be my wife's therapist i
can't
won't be if she says hey i got this
homework assignment what does this mean
then i might tell her i might give that
homework assignment to a client if
x y z um but i'm not ever going to
be her count i can't right and so i
think it's sitting down and letting your
mom and your sister know
hey i'm grieving this with y'all and i'm
not in these appointments i don't know
and this is my dad and so i'm not going
to be the nurse here
if you're comfortable with interpreting
right if they can put you on
speakerphone when a doctor
um calls is meeting with them or you can
step away and come over to a meeting
just to interpret great but you don't
need to be the person telling your mom
that
dad's got 16 months that doesn't need to
be your job you need to be
the daughter who hugs her mom when your
dad gets a bad
prognosis right does that make sense
yeah it does you know it's one of those
things that i immediately feel like when
i'm getting a call from
my mom or my sister that i'm taking off
the
sister or daughter hat and immediately
putting the medical hat on because i
know they're a mess
so and so you know you're trying to be
like the strong person
and hey not your other hand right
not true you know i'm grieving this with
with friends and
colleagues like i don't feel like i can
even grieve this with my own family
so here a great great gift you can give
your mom and your sister
is what you just said this is my daddy
not one of my patients and i'm not i
don't work in oncology i don't you might
work in oncology but
it doesn't sound like you're a cancer
doctor
and um i
i don't know all i know is that my
daddy's really sick it doesn't look
great and i need my sister and my mom
and if we get some news some kind of
medical jargon i'm happy to interpret
um but i just need my sister and my mom
right now
and so please don't ask any more medical
questions anymore i don't know i just
don't know these things but i know that
i need you guys
and i think that conversation among
three women who love each other dearly
and three women who are hurting in
unique and different ways
will be really powerful and important
and for whatever it's worth megan i'm so
so sorry that your dad
is sick so so sorry
oh thank you so much he's a good guy huh
yeah i mean he he's a guy that he
doesn't say much but
you know he truly it's you know he gives
the shirt off his back he sounds like a
six to seven day a week working
midwestern mail right
yeah and so i mean for him like
obviously
obviously the cancer diagnosis in and of
itself i worry about
but you know he went from being an
independent guy to
a feeding tube and a walker and i mean
everything's been stripped from him and
the way you just described that as
a very clinical way and that's how
you're trained
to work through these situations i want
you to allow yourself whether it's with
your husband hopefully it's with your
sister
and your mom too
allow yourself to just sit in the
devastation of this powerful strong man
who we
who carried us through life now on a
feeding tube
right there's a part of that that has to
be witnessed you've got to go through
that process
holding this at arm's length like you do
with your patience is a recipe for this
thing hanging on to you for the rest of
your life
and so don't rob yourself of the
grieving process
get right smack in the middle of it and
it will make you an empathetic caretaker
moving forward it'll make you a great
sister
but most importantly you got to be a
celebrating daughter
of a guy who carried the family through
and it's slowly slowly leaving us man
i'm grateful grateful for your call and
we'll be thinking about you guys i'll be
praying about you guys
and um yeah
i think it's gonna be a powerful
conversation for you i really do
and
cancer sucks i hate it
hate it hate it hate it hate it
by the way tell your dad that you love
him
make sure you tell him that a lot not as
nurse megan but his daughter begging
make sure your dad knows that write him
a letter so he can read it
tell him what a great guy he was what a
great example he was what a powerful
example he was all those things
let him know oh man